la jeune femme va donc reprendre son
récit de la soirée du 5 janvier
1994 et voici cette fois ce qui selon
elle s'est vraiment passé elle vient à
20h15 rendre visite à son époux à sa
demande la discussion au départ se
déroule sans problème et à un moment
elle lui dit si je revenais vivre ici
estce que ça serait pas une une bonne
idée et là elle seur à un refus
catégorie qui lui dit pas
[Applaudissements]
question nous sommes le 5 janvier
1994 à Chantilly dans l'Oise il fait
nuit noire les rues sont
désertes à 23h30 la gendarmerie reçoit
un coup de téléphone à l'autre bout du
fil
Christophe un jet
professionnel l'homme semble paniquer
l'histoire porte sur un différent
familial visiblement et c'est un homme
qui appelle donc Christophe qui appelle
au secours qui demande au gendarmes de
venir l'aider parce qu'il est en
difficulté dans une scène de ménage
l'appel est peu banal Christophe
lescrill dit être menacé par sa femme
Nathalie âgée de 27 ans la situation est
si critique que les gendarmes décident
d'intervenir 20 minutes plus tard les
forces de l'ordre arrivent sur les li
et ils ne sont pas les seuls sur
place deux femmes elles aussi alerté par
Christophe lesr sont là et elles ont
l'air
inquiète l'une d'elles Cline Cortier se
souvient on arrive au Pavillon on se
présente au gendarmes et on fait le tour
du pavillon avec
eux donc ensemble ils vont faire le tour
de la maison pour voir porte une fenêtre
par extraordinaire serait
ouverte mais il n'y a pas â qui viv dans
cette maison les portes sont fermées
personne ne répond mais par contre les
lumières sont toutes
allumé une autre personne arrive sur les
lieux il s'agit de Patricia bertiglia
c'est la belle-mère de
Christophe depuis quelques temps elle
vit dans cette maison et ce soir-là elle
rentre d'un dîner grâce à son double des
clés elle ouvre immédiatement la porte
au forces de l'ordre
lorsque les gendarmes accompagnent
madame bertiglia pour visiter le
domicile ils font le rez-de-chaussée ne
constat aucun désordre monte à l'étage
dans les
chambres et aucun désordre non plus ni
dans la salle de bain ni dans toutes les
pièces la maison est vide aucune trace
ni de Christophe ni de son épouse
Nathalie ni de leur fille de 18 mois
Maya ils semble avoir tous disparu et
chose curieuse les papiers identité de
Christophe et ses vêtements sont là tout
indique un départ précipité n ni montre
ni portefeuille ni papier d'identité ni
manteau sur
lui c'est pas l'habitude de Christophe
de sortir en jogging basket t-shirt en
plein mois de janvier quand il gèle et
et encore moins d'y emmener sa fille par
un froid pareil où se trouve la famille
le pourquo parti de chez lui alors qu'il
venait d'alerter la
gendarmerie ça surprend un petit peu les
gendarmes de voir qu'il y avait personne
suite à l'appel qui était quand même
environ un quart d'heure avant mais bon
les couples sont un peu particuliers
quand ce-ci dispute on ne sait jamais
leur décision à l'instanté donc pour les
gendarmes
effectivement c'était bizarre mais comme
il n'y avait pas d'indice de crime ou
délit trace de lutte pour eux le couple
pouvait être parti pour un autre motif
pour les gendarmes rien d'alarmant à
priori il décide de quitter les lieux en
revanche Céline et son ami ont un
mauvais pressentiment elle décide de
rester sur place et de fouiller les
environs 2h passent lorsqu'une voiture
s'approche du
pavillon il est environ 2h du matin
c'est Nathalie qui réapparaît avec sa
fille seulement Christophe lui n'est pas
là les deux amis de Christophe lescrill
observent ce qu'il se passe un peu à
l'écart
elle voit Nathalie confier la petite
Maya à sa mère Patricia
bertiglia puis la jeune femme repart
seule quelques minutes
après le départ de Nathalie nous
revenons au domicile de Christophe voir
madame bertigtiglia qui était en train
de coucher la
petite et nous lui avons demandé si tout
se passait bien si la petite allait bien
et si elle avait des nouvelles de
Christophe et à ce moment-là elle nous a
dit avoir posé le moins de questions
possible à sa fille et que sa fille lui
avait juste dit que il s'était disputé
qu'elle avait pris la petite et qu'elle
était partie 3h après le coup de
téléphone de Christophe lesrill au
gendarmes Céline et son ami n'ont
toujours aucune explication sur la
mystérieuse disparition du jokeet et
elle redoute le
[Musique]
pire les deux femmes vont passer toute
la nuit à chercher Christophe en
[Musique]
20 le lendemain le 6 janvier Nathalie
lescrill se présente à la gendarmerie de
Chantilly la jeune femme semble morte
d'inquiétude car son mari n'est pas
rentré de la nuit elle explique au
gendarmes que Christophe et elle se sont
séparés depuis déjà plusieurs mois et
confirment que la veille au soir ils se
sont viol disputé lors de son audition
Nathalie lcrill paraissait affolé elle
déclare qu'elle était venue pour essayer
de se réconcilier à sa demande avec son
son mari et la l'altercation une
altercation s'en est
suivie l'enfant s'est mise à pleurer
elle a voulu monter pour la consoler et
à ce moment-là la dispute éclate parce
qu'il lui dit écoute ça fait 8 mois que
tu t'en es pas occupé tu as pas
commencer maintenant tu as rien à faire
ici et il empêche
physiquement à en devenir violent
d'approcher l'enfant Nathalie raconte
qu'elle s'est réfugiée dans la chambre
de leur fille mais Christophe l'aurait
poursuivi et chose incroyable il aurait
tenté de
l'étrangler elle aurait réussi à lui
échapper mais de justesse
elle a pris peur elle a pris son
véhicule au moment où lui répondit un
appel téléphonique au rez-de-chaussée et
en prenant son enfant elle n'a regagné
son domicile que bien plus tard la SE l'
image qui lui restait c'est de voir dans
son rétroviseur Christophe leskrill qui
lui cour après en jogging et en T-shirt
dans la rue cette image de son mari
poursuivant sa voiture est donc la
dernière que Nathalie a gardé en
mémoire depuis la jeune femme jure ne
plus avoir eu de nouvelles de Christophe
seulement les gendarmes sont perplexes
car le récit de la jeune femme ne colle
pas du tout avec le coup de fil donné
par Christophe Le Scrill la veille aux
enquêteurs alors Christophe a-t-il fui
après avoir tenté d'étrangler sa femme
ou au contraire a-t-il été menacé
physiquement par celle-ci comme il l'a
affirmé au téléphone il faut maintenant
retrouver le jockeet son signalement est
envoyé à toutes les
[Musique]
polices et rapidement des batus sont
organisé dans les forêts des
[Musique]
environs une vingtaine de militaires
sont mis en place pour afin de de
sillonner le secteur la id du LCE et des
équipes cinophiles aussi pour essayer de
remonter la trace de fuite ou la
direction de fuite de Christophe l
seulement les recherches ne donnent rien
alors il faut maintenant fouiller le
passé du jeune homme pour tenter de
trouver la clé de
[Musique]
l'énigme les enquêteurs interrogent un
par un tous les proches du jockeet
disparu amis è et membre de sa famille
tous décrivent un jeune homme sans
histoire durant les auditions tout le
monde le considér considère comme un
garçon
courageux fiable présent
disponible toujours à rendre service
c'est un type gentil assez
effacé
qui n c'est pas un meneur d'homme c'est
pas un battant c'est pas c'est pas un
type qui a un caractère très affirmé
c'est plutôt quel quelquun c'est plutôt
un tempérament de suiveur c'est
quelqu'un de pondéré qui aime la vie de
famille et qui aime particulièrement sa
petite fille sur le plan professionnel
tout sourit à Christophe leskrille à
l'époque c'est un jockeet renommé qui a
24 ans a déjà gagné plus de 150
courses Christophe lescr il est en pass
de devenir l' des meilleurs jockey de sa
génération il a gagné beaucoup de
courses 24
l'année qui a précédé sa sa disparition
et puis surtout il a gagné le le le pigé
d'or de ville qui a un prix très très
réputé s'il tombe sur le bon cheval qui
peut lui faire gagner trois quatre
bonnes courses il est il est dans les 5
si meilleurs sûrement il a jamais eu
d'ennemi ni professionnellement et ni
vie privée parce que dans la vie privée
voilà c'est une personne très très calme
et tout donc je vois pas de d'ennemi
potentiel envers Christophe non
pas d'ennemis une carrière en pleine
ascension Christophe lescrill est un
père de famille attentionné et un
professionnel apprécié les gendarmes ont
bien du mal à croire que le jeune homme
est tenté d'étrangler sa
femme alors cette disparition elle est
elle est un peu plus étrange parce que
Christophe lescrille avait pas de raison
objective de disparaître il avait pour
son entourage aucune raison objective de
disparaître il avait sa fille donc il
s'occupait beaucoup qu'il adorait avait
des engagements
professionnels il avait jamais manifesté
la moine intention de disparaître de
mettre fin à séjour de de de ça paraît
complètement sa disparition paraît
complètement
aberrante d'autant qu'un élément attire
l'attention des enquêteurs et montre que
la disparition du jookeet n'est pas
volontaire les enquêteurs de la
gendarmerie vont étudier les comptes
bancaires de Christophe lescrill l'échec
les mouvements de de comptte les
utilisations de carte bancaire et ils
vont s'apercevoir qu'il n'y a aucun
mouvement aucune émission de chèque tout
laisse penser qu'il est arrivé quelque
chose de grave à Christophe
leskrill désormais le jockeet ne fait
plus la Une de La presspique mais celle
de la rubrique fit divers des
journaux mystérieuse disparition à
laamorlé dans l'Oise où depuis le 5
janvier dernier le jocket Christophe
lescr n'a pas de signe de vie et il y a
un homme qui le connaît bien et qui est
inquiet c'est Yan Porzier l'entraîneur
de
Christophe je pense que c'éit un garçon
très correct je pense qu'il m'aurait
donné des nouvelles il aurait
certainement donné des nouvelles à sa
mère qu'il adore et donc je suis très
très inquiet et très pessimiste
l'enquête est au point mort alors les
gendarmes décident de s'intéresser de
plus près à la dernière personne à avoir
vu le disparu Nathalie lecrill sa femme
ils en sont persuadés c'est là que se
trouve la clé du
mystère Christophe et Nathalie se
rencontre en juin 1990 dans l'univers
des
courspiques tous les deux partagent la
même passion pour les chevaux à l'époque
Christophe est apprenti Jocky nathalie
est en charge de l'entraînement des
chevaux Thierry Gillet est le meilleur
ami de Christophe et il se souvient de
la première fois où le jeune homme lui a
parlé de Nathalie Christophe rencontre
Natalie sur les hippodromees c'est elle
fait partie du du milieu son grand-père
était
entraîneur la famille propriétaire de
chevau donc elle fréquente les courses
Christophe tombe fou amoureux de
Nathalie le vrai coup de foud vraiment
le coup de foudre moi le lendemain il me
voit il me dit j'ai rencontré une fille
super c'est Nathalie elle est géniale on
va ensemble 3 mois après ils étaient
mariés ça s'est passé très vite ça a été
fulgurant
[Musique]
il était là il l'
laçait je me marrais elle va pas
s'échapper et il me disait toujours
monsieur porziier c'est ma force c'est
ma force Christophe est un joquet
montant natthalie respecte tout ça elle
est derrière lui elle l'aide elle le
pousse elle lui parle c'est un peu
s'amuse à cet époque le couple ne se
quitte pas d'une somelle Christophe et
Nathalie sortent fréquemment et se
rendent à des soir mondain pour la plus
grande joie de la jeune
femme mais les enquêteurs vont vite
découvrir que les proches du jookeet ne
voient pas toujours d'un très bon œil la
relation fusionnelle de Christophe et de
Nathalie Nathalie influence beaucoup
Christophe sur sur ses choix dans la vie
privée l'écarte beaucoup de de ses amis
qu'il avait depuis très longtemps alors
les
raisons je sais pas pourquoi mais tout
suite elle arrive à faire le
ménage autour de lui en en lui en levant
c'est certaines fréquentations qu'elle
estime à mon avis pas bien je sais pas
très vite la passion va s'émousser et
cela à cause d'un événement familial qui
va tout
[Musique]
bouleverser en juillet
1992 2 ans après leur rencontre Nathalie
donne naissance à une petite fille
nommée Maya Christophe est ravi mais la
jeune maman elle va soudainement changer
de comportement en effet Nathalie
supporte assez mal ce nouveau rôle de
mère au foyer a besoin de s'évader c'est
à ce moment-là que sa relation amoureuse
avec Christophe connaît ses premières
difficultés après l'accouchement
Nathalie va être prise d'une frénésie de
sortie elle a besoin de sortir elle
s'ennuie chez elle elle trouve que son
mari est trop casagier qui s'occupe trop
de sa fille qu'il est trop à la maison
et du coup à peine 3 mois après son
accouchement la voilà partie elle va en
boîte de nuit elle sort elle rentre à
pas d'heure euh mais seule le schéma
c'était que Christophe était
laababiciteur et que et que naalie
sortait en
boîteilà avec qui j'en sais rien mais
surtout avec des garçons d'après ce que
j'ai pu comprendre en fait le
comportement extravagant de Nathalie
cache une réalité bien plus sombre la
jeune femme souffre de dépression à tel
point qu'un jour elle a envisagé le pire
en mai
nathalie est au bout du chemin elle est
au bout de cette longue dépression
nerveuse qui la travaille depuis la
naissance de sa fille Maya et elle va
tenter de mettre fin à ses jours en se
coupant les veines
8 mois avant la disparition de
Christophe nathalie lesrill est admise
dans le service de réanimation de
l'hôpital Saint-Anne à Paris elle y
restera 4 jours à sa sortie elle décide
de se séparer de son mari et de lui
laisser la garde de leur petite fille de
mois pour le jeune homme c'est un
épisode très
douloureux quand Nathalie quitte le
qu'on quitte Christophe Christophe est
un petit peu complètement je un peu
déboussolé parce que il est encore
amoureux c'est elle qui prend la
décision de partir c'est pas lui donc
c'est l'elle de son côté donc Christophe
est un peu perdu parce qu'il est
amoureux de Nathalie
donc euh voilà comme quand on se fait
quand on se fait larguer comme on dit
hein quand quand on se sépare il y a
toujours un malheureux et le malheureux
c'était Christophe natthalie losr quitte
le domicile conjugal de la morle elle
emménage chez des amis qui possèdent un
poney club à 10 km de là en échange du
git et du couvert elle donne des cours
d'équitation Christophe de son côté
espère toujours que sa femme reviendra
vers
lui mais un terrible aveux va
définitivement briser son
couple
un jour alors que Nathalie est revenue à
laamorlaet pour voir sa fille une
nouvelle querelle éclate avec Christophe
et c'est à ce moment-l que la jeune
femme fait une révélation à son mari
lors d'une dispute du
couple Christophe et Nathalie se
prennent de bec ils sont déjà séparés et
naalie dans un moment de colère intense
va lui avouer d'abord qu'elle a couché
avec certain nombre de ses copains mais
pire encore elle va surtout lui
expliquer qu' l'enfant que la petite
Maya n'est peut-être pas de lui
Christophe est est déboussolé pas parce
que elle a couché avec plein d'hommes
mais parce qu'elle lui annonce qu'il est
peut-être pas le père donc essaie de se
renseigner et savoir si ce qu'elle lui a
dit est vraiment vrai et me demande
est-ce que tu es au courant que Nathalie
fréquente fréquente et me sort des noms
de de personnes et jooké en me disant
est-ce que est-ce que tu es au courant
donc je lu je lui confirme
bah ce que je connais je lu confirme oui
elle a couché avec telle personne
pendant que tu étais marié avec je sais
une chose un jour il est venu me voir
dans la saellerie parce que c'est pas
que j'étais très paternel avec lui mais
mais on avait des des des relations
assez chaleureuses en dehors du boulot
et un jour il m'a dit Monsieur porziier
est-ce que vous croyez que je devrais
faire une recherche en paternité
vis-à-vis de ma
fille je lu dit écoute ta fille tu
l'aimes dit oui monsieur por je l'aime
écoute continue à l'aimer et fait rien
du tout et c'est ce qu'il a fait il m'a
écoutter Christophe ne fera donc pas de
recherche en
paternité en revanche il décide
d'entamer une procédure de divorce il va
même jusqu'à demander aux hommes ayant
eu des relations sexuelles avec Nathalie
de lui rédiger des attestations
d'adultère dans le but d'obtenir la
garde de sa
fille Nathalie le sait en cas de divorce
elle perd tout une vie confortable et la
garde de sa fille alors du jour au
lendemain son comportement va changer et
choses incroyable Christophe va devenir
son souffre douleur Christophe est un
homme battu ils vont même retrouver une
plainte qui remonte au mois de septembre
1993 soit 4 mois avant sa disparition où
il se plaint auprès des gendarmes
d'avoir été frappé par Nathalie à l'aide
d'une poignée de
porte il a d'ailleurs 3 jours d'ITT
d'interruption de travail la seule
anecdote ce que j'ai vu c'est le jour où
il a levé son t-shirt et il avait des
ébrures dans le dos comme le comme le
pouce donc ça c'était pas un cheval qu'
lu avait fait et en tempant jqu quand on
change on se on se déabit totalement
pour pour s'habiller en choquer donc
quand il était à côté de moi il se
déshabillait je voyais je voyais
quelques marques donc donc il pe pas me
dire que c'était des coups chute de
cheval le matin ou entraînement alors
les gendarmes se demandent si cette
femme violente avec son mari n'aurait
pas pu aller plus loin jusqu'à le faire
disparaître dès lors Nathalie lescrill
devient le suspect numéro 1 même s'il ne
dispose ni de preuve ni de mobile les
enquêteurs décident d'interroger la
jeune
F cela fait maintenant 9 jours que
Christophe lescrill n'a donné signe de
vie lorsque les enquêteurs auditionnent
Nathalie à propos du soir de la
disparition de son mari ils veulent en
savoir plus sur son emploi du temps
entre
23h45 le moment où elle a quitté le
domicile conjugal avec sa fille et 2h du
matin le moment où elle est revenu
déposer l'enfant à sa
mère et Nathalie va révéler un élément
qu'elle n'avait pas mentionné
jusque-l le 14 janvier lors de sa 2e
audition Nathalie lescrill rajoute que
cette nuit-là pour prouver son innocence
elle avait pris un un
autostoppeur et elle donne quelques
éléments pour qu'on puisse l'identifier
afin de pouvoir l'entendre confirmer
cette
[Musique]
version donc les gendarmes vont se
mettre à la recherche de cet
autostoppeur et grâce aux éléments
qu'elle a fourni il finissent par le
retrouver ils vont l'entendre et il va
confirmer il va confirmer deux
choses la présence de Nathalie cette
nuit-là au volant de sa voiture ça c'est
à quiis mais il va confirmer
également qu'elle est avec
Maya la petite fille naalie aurait donc
dit la
vérité pourtant les gensarm sont pas
entièrement
convaincus pour en savoir plus les
enquêteurs vont tenter un coup de poker
ils vont espionner les conversation
téléphonique de la jeune
[Musique]
femme 25 janvier
1994 les gendarmes placent Nathalie
leskrill sur écoute téléphonique leur
premier constat c'est que la jeune femme
qui se montrait très inquiète à propos
de la disparition de son mari devant eux
adopte un comportement bien différent
dans le privé
lors de différents contacts qu'on avait
pu avoir avec elle elle était les tr/4s
du temps en larme é pleoré à la
recherche de son mari et au téléphone
rien ne transpirait sur ce comportement
les conversations qu'elle pouvait avoir
avec les différents interlocuteurs
qu'elle avait nous laissait penser à une
fille heureuse de vivre pas du tout
stressée par la disparition de son mari
donc ces élémentsl été plus que
troublant pour nous et ce n'est pas tout
quelques jours seulement après la
disparition de son mari à la plus grande
surprise des proches de Christophe
nathalie est revenue s'installer dans le
domicile conjugal comme si de rien
n'était si Christophe était revenu à ce
moment-là Christophe n'aurait absolument
pas accepté que Nathalie a réintégré la
maison de cette
[Musique]
façon plus étonnant encore Nathalie se
complète à étaler son histoire dans les
médias elle accepte de nombreuses
interviews et accueille volonti et dans
le pavillon familial les journalistes
qui souhaitent la rencontrer et voici ce
qu'elle dit à propos de Christophe il
avait les trit tiré par la colère jamais
je ne l'ai vu dans un tel état j'ai vu
Christophe qui me poursuivait à pied
après il a
disparu pour moi c'est une fugue mon
mari est sans doute allé chercher refug
chez des
amis seulement Nathalie Le Scrill est
bavarde et à force de parler elle va
finir par trop en dire
[Musique]
parmi les journalistes venus interviewer
Nathalie au domicile de la Morla il y a
Cécile
Baulieu je suis allé la voir chez elle
donc dans le pavillon qu' qu'elle occupé
avec son mari
elle est plutôt plutôt avenante plutôt
plutôt sympathique elle a envie de
parler de la disparition de son mari ça
c'est
sûr elle prend le temps de seevir elle
m'emène dans la cuisine elle fait du thé
et puis elle me raconte la dernière
soirée qu'elle a passé avec lui avant sa
disparition mais il y a un détail dans
le récit de Nathalie lerill qui va faire
naître les soupçons de la
journaliste alors moi je lui demande
plusieurs fois de me raconter cette
soirée parce que je sais pas il y a des
choses qui me semblent pas très
cohérentes et donc elle me redit une
fois encore qu'elle s'est enfermée à clé
dans la dans la cuisine donc où je me
trouve et je remarque que la porte de la
cuisine n'a pas de n'a pas de fermeture
les clenches ont été enlevées et donc il
est absolument impossible de s'enfermer
dans la cuisine à ce moment-là je
médicalement et que la scne n'a pas du
tout pu se passer comme elle comme elle
comme elle le raconte surveillé par les
gendarmes considéré comme une menteuse
par les journalistes nathalie loskrill
est au cœur de tous les
soupçons le 7 février 1994 l'affaire
bascule
un homme se présente à la gendarmerie de
Chantilly il a des révélations
importantes à faire cet homme s'appelle
Didier fau il connaît bien Nathalie car
sa fille prend des cours de poney auprès
d'elle et voici ce qu'il est venu dire
aux
enquêteurs ce témoin raconte aux
gendarmes que le lendemain de la
disparition de Christophe Nathalie
loscrill qui est une de ses amis lui a
demandé de l'accompagner dans la forêt
de Viller s sale et dans cette forêt
Didier F raconte que Nathalie lerill
s'est livré à un étrange manège lui ne
descend pas de la voiture elle
descend en courant remontant le chemin
s'enfonçant dans le bois elle s'est
absenté environ un quart d'heure et
quand elle est revenue elle était
couverte de terre elle avait le visage
blême elle lui a dit bon et viens vite
on s'en va il y a des gens qui qui
veulent
m'attraper le témoin dit j'ai regardais
autour il y avait personne mais je me
suis exécuté j'ai elle est monté elle
était pâle comme un
linge nathalieill lui demande alors de
ne parler à personne de cet épisode mais
pourquoi Nathalie lescrill est-elle
venue dans ce
bois C information est capitale pour les
gendarmes on cherche depuis plus d'un
mois Christophe et là d'un seul coup on
a un témoin qui dit que le lendemain il
a emmené la sa femme en forêt qu'elle
est revenue pleine de terre
al ça commence à sentir bon entre
guillemets les gendarmes accompagné du
témoin se rendent immédiatement sur
place ils cadrillent la zone et leurs
pires craintes vont être bientôt
confirmé peu de temps après le arrivée
au lieu dit le bois
Saint-Michel dans les haau de Viller
sous
sa-leu le uncp est découvert sous
débranchag une cordelette autour du
cou un corps seul avec un bas de jogging
d'une personne de petite taille faible
corpulence immédiatement le
rapprochement est fait avec le corps de
Christophe lescr appelé en renfort les
équipes scientifiques de la gendarmerie
arrivent sur place et confirme
rapidement l'identité de la victime et
les causes de sa
mort Christophe loskrill a été tué par
strangulation sur place aucun indice
mais tout laisse penser que Nathalie
lescrill est impliquée dans le
meurtre dès le lendemain les enquêteurs
placent Nathalie leskrill en garde à vue
il décide de questionner la jeune femme
sans lui faire part de la découverte du
corps de son mari ce jour-là
nathalie est plutôt sereine elle réitère
ses deux premières auditions dans le
même sens en disant qu'elle a pris ils
sont disputés elle a pris son enfant
après elle a rajouté qu'effectivement
elle avait ramené un autostoppeur donc
l'audition était disons-nous bon enfant
seulement très vite le ton change ils
vont lui mettre la
pression en gros il l'accusent ils
disent c'est toi qui a tué ton mari mais
il en donneent pas plus et là là ils
comprennent rapidement qu'ils ont
affaire à quelqu'un qui a un vrai
caractère qui ne se laisse pas faire qui
est une vraie colérique et ça se passe
mal et là elle se braque ne veut plus
rien entendre elle se coupe elle se elle
se rétracte
elle ne veut plus parler quoi les
gendarmes décident alors d'expliquer à
Nathalie ce que Didier FA est venu leur
raconter le lendemain de la disparition
de Christophe lorsqu'il l'a conduite en
forêt
là elle a commencé à être un peu
déstabilisée demandant si c'était vrai
si c'était pas vrai si nous avions des
éléments ou si nous avions pas et là ça
fait l'effet inverse elle devient folle
elle se met à hurler en disant mais je
le connais pas qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette histoire mais pour qui vous me
prenez vous pensez que c'est moi
l'assassin elle devient complètement
hystérique elle devient complètement
folle elle se met à
hurler deuxième échec enfit il elle a
vraiment un caractère incroyable cette
femme pas facile à manœuvrer hein les
gendarmes n'ont plus le choix ils
comprennent que Nathalie ne leur avouera
rien d'elle-même ils doivent provoquer
un électrochoc ils lui disent bon allez
maintenant ça suffit on arrête de jouer
on a retrouvé le corps de votre mari il
était à l'endroit où le fameux témoin
dont vous n avez pas voulu entendre
parler tout à
l'heure nous a emmené et où il vous a
emmené et c'est là qu'on a trouvé le
corps de votre mari donc faut arrêter de
jouer lorsque on lui dit que le corps a
été retrouvé directement elle monte en
crise
elle elle a dû être retenue d'ailleurs
parce qu'elle s'énervait elle n'était
pas entravée ni rien de tout ça elle
s'énervait elle dû retenu elle est
montée dans une crise un peu
hystérique
et il a fallu retrouver
tout notre calme pour euh ramener le
sien quoi elle voulait pas croire entre
guillemets qu'elle euh que l'on avait le
corps de de son mari elle ne voulait pas
y croire à ce moment-là Nathalie
leskrill a compris qu'elle avait
perdu et elle décide de passer aux
œes la jeune femme va donc reprendre son
récit de la soirée du 5 janvier
1994 et voici cette fois ce qui selon
elle c'est vraiment passé elle vient à
20h15 rendre visite à son époux à sa
demande euh la discussion au départ se
déroule sans problème et à un moment
elle lui dit bah si je revenait vivre
ici est-ce que ça serait pas une une
bonne idée et là elle se heurte à un
refus catégorique qui lui dit il y en a
pas question mais il en est même pas
question l'enfant doit être couché se
mettre à pleurer Nathalie veut euh la
prendre dans ses bras la réconforter
Christophe refuse dit non ça fait
plusieurs mois 8 mois que tu es pas là
tu peux pas aller t'en occuper
maintenant euh une première échaufourée
passe entre eux et elle euh elle monte
euh dans la salle de bain pour se
rafraîchir selon Nathalie Christophe
lescrille l'a rejoint dans la salle de
bain et euh aurait tenté de l'étrangler
une première fois avec la cordelette
d'un d'un d'une robe de chambre il est
allé derrière moi dans la salle de bain
et lorsque j'ai voulu sortir il m'a
accroché une cordelette autour du
cou il
ser se détache de de cette ceinture et à
ce momentl lui part dans les escaliers
parce que le téléphone
sonne le téléphone a sonné je me suis
dégagé Christophe a pris la cordelette
et l'a passé autour de son
cou geste inexplicable pouroi Christophe
aurait-il passé cette ceinture autour de
son cou Nathalie lecrill ne le précise
pas mais ce détail joue un rôle
important dans la suite de sa version
des faits Christophe la rejoint dans la
chambre lui saute dessus tente de
l'étrangler la petite se met à pleurer
du coup il lâche son
étreinte il quitte la chambre il a la
corde de son peignoir la ceinture de son
peignoir autour du cou Nathalie descend
court après lui dans l'escalier euh se
saisit des des bouts de cette ceinture
et tire violemment en arrière
déséquilibré Christophe tombe dans
l'escalier du coup lui il part il
bascule il se heurte la tête sur un
recoin sur un coin de marche
et il est esturbi et ayant peur de de sa
réaction
elle fait un nœud à cette ceinture qui
se trouve autour du cou de son
épou je ne me souviens plus si j'ai
serré ou ce que j'ai fait exactement
entre le moment où il est tombé et le
moment où j'ai fait le nœud tout va très
[Musique]
vite j'ai pris peur sachant que vous
alliez arriver j'ai décidé de
m'enfuir
elle sait qu'il faut pas traîner sur les
lieux une fois qu'elle a tué Christophe
elle sait que les gendarmes vont arriver
d'une minute à l'autre donc elle file
chercher sa fille dans sa chambre elle
l'installe dans la voiture ensuite elle
va prendre le cadavre de son mari elle
va le traîner jusqu'à la voiture
elle le colle sur la place sur le siège
passager tê
bêche
et ensuite elle prend sa gamine sur les
genoux et elle
démarre arrivé au bois Saint-Michel
Nathalie lescrille descend du véhicule
laisse son enfant dans celui-ci puis
ouvre la portière passager avantroit et
tire le corps de son mari le traînant à
travers le
chemin en le tirant son t-shirt rester
dans les mains et ses baskets sont tombé
donc
elle cache le corps dans des feuillages
et elle récupère les baskets et le
t-shirt Nathalie los affirme qu'ensuite
elle est repartie s débarrasser des
affaires de son mari dans une poubelle
et à Lavit sa voiture pour dissimuler
son
crime ensite pris dans sa voiture un
jeune
autostoppeur qu'elle a déposé quelques
kilomètres plus
loin et 2 heures plus tard elle est
revenue au domicile de son mari pour
déposer l'enfant à sa
mère au terme de sa garde à vue nathalie
lesrill est incarcérée à la maison
d'arrêt de
Bovet cependant malgré aveux l'enquête
est loin d'être finie car deux points
dans le récit de Nathalie pose problème
à la juge d'instruction Martine pernolet
tout d'abord elle aimit des doutes quant
à la tentative d'étranglement dont la
jeune femme dit avoir été victime quand
Natalie
lerill nous indique que Christophe a
tenté de l'étrangler on peut être un peu
dubitatif
contenu du caractère calme de la victime
et par contre de la violence dont peut
faire preuve
Nathalie donc nous n'y croyons pas
forcément mais c'est sa version nous
n'avons rien pour la contredire à ce
moment-là mais ce n'est pas tout la juge
s'interroge également sur la capacité de
Nathalie à commettre ce crime tel
qu'elle l'a
raconté il s'agit d'une femme qui serait
auteur d'un meurtre ce qui n'est pas si
courant et la victime est un homme donc
que la question que je me pose que se
posent les enquêteurs était-elle seu au
moment du crime et au moment du
transport du corps qui représente quand
même une charge non négligeable mais si
Nathalie n'a pas tué son mari seul alors
qui aurait pu l'aider les gendarmes
savent que natthalie est assez isolée
finalement elle a peu d'amis elle a
beaucoup d'amant mais elle a peu d'amis
donc qu' faut
pour ce type d'action quelqu'un de très
proche finalement c'est pas le vague
copain qu'on qu'on a rencontré un soir
dans une boîte de nuit qu'on appelle en
disant tiens j'ai tué mon mari viens
m'aider alors ils vont chercher la mère
la mère elle a un alibi en béton elle
était à un dîner en région
parisienne on l'a vu
arriver ça colle pas les gendarme
s'oriente alors vers le père de la jeune
femme un homme dont le casier judiciaire
est plutôt
chargé il a été plusieurs fois condamné
par le passé et à l'époque il est même
recherché par la justice et fait l'objet
de plusieurs mandats
d'arrêt nous interpellons en fait le
père Nathalie lecrill sur Paris
et après l'avoir
entendu
vérifier son
alibi rien ne pourra lui être reproché
nous en profiterons pour mettre à
exécution les mains à d'arrêt dont il
faisait l'objet et il sera écroué en
prison le de père et la mère de Nathalie
étant disculpé la thèse d'un éventuel
complice est pour l'instant dans une
impasse pourtant les doutes demeurent et
c'est la reconstitution judiciaire qui
va définitivement les
[Musique]
dissiper 4 mai
1994 la juge d'instruction et les
gendarmes se rendent avec Nathalie
lecrill dans son ancien domicile à la
morlé leur but est de réaliser la
constitution du meurtre de Christophe et
contre toute attente la journée démarre
de manière détendue elle s'y prête
volontiers elle est
agréable
souriante nous discutons même
ensemble comme un acteur de cinéma
Nathalie Le Scrill directement s'est
mise en jeu exactement dans le même même
timing la même force les même précision
tout était réglé par elle sans avoir à
lui dire vous avez fait ci vous avez
fait ça il y avait même pas besoin de
reprendre le scénario qu'elle avait
déclaré parce que c'était le scénario
tel qu'elle nous l'avait fait sans
qu'une question lui soit posée vient
enfin le moment clé de cette
reconstitution celui où Nathalie doit
transporter un mannequin de taille et de
poids équivalent à celui de son mari
autrement dit 1,58 et 52 kg alors que la
jeune femme elle est plus petite elle
effectue le premier transport entre la
maison et le véhicule qui est garé je
dirais 3 4 m de
l'entrée je suis un peu inquiète je me
demande comment cela va se passer et
elle effectue ce transport avec une
facilité
déconcertante sans aucun effort sans
aucun une trace de d'énervement ni rien
a transporter le corps la renverser
comme elle avait dit dans le véhicule
sans aucun mouvement désordon
de personnes qui av des difficultés
aucune difficulté faire cette malvre
pour la juge d'instruction ça ne fait
plus aucun doute Natalie n'a pas eu
besoin d'aide elle a tué son mari seul
et a caché son cors sans aucune
complicité pourant il reste une question
le meurre comme l'a affirmé Natalie la
conséquence d'uneè dispute ou bien
s'agit-il d'un meurtre prémédité par une
jeune femme instable c'est à la justice
de trancher
20 novembre
1996 à la cour d'assise de Bovet ouvre
le procès de Nathalie
lescrill un procès très
attendu la petite salle d'audience de la
cour d'assise de beauovva n'était pas
assez grande cet après-midi pour
accueillir le nombreux public un public
qui apercevra de loin la ceinture de
payoir qui a étrangler Christophe
lesrill la salle est comble le jour de
l'ouverture du procès de de Nathalie Le
Scrill tous les mondes sentre choc il y
a le monde des chevaux il y a les les
jockets il y a les collègues de travail
de de Christophe il y a la famille de
Christophe il y a la famille de Nathalie
et puis elle est apparue dans le box
avec un petit tailleur gris les cheveux
ramassés en arrière par une queue de
cheval elle avait beaucoup maigri le
procè s'annonce difficile pour l'accuser
car son comportement joue en sa
défaveur et elle va tender de séduire à
la fois les
jurés les
magistrats
et et puis puis ça fait flop quoi ça
fait flop parce que ça ça ça passe pas
ça marche pas elle essaie de de nous
faire prendre des vissil pour des
lanterne et ça a été effectivement très
compliqué parce qu'on a une
Nathalie comment dire qui s'exprimait
pas très bien qui qui qui faisait pas
naturel et et du coup peu sincère plutôt
donnant l'impression d'être peu sincère
et ça c'était vra évidemment
catastrophique les témoignages se
succèdent à la barre le portrait dressé
de Nathalie lerill et sans complaisance
a commencé par celui de l'expert
psychiatre Roland coutanau qui revient
notamment sur la nature de la relation
entre Nathalie et
Christophe elle avait l'habitude
finalement d'une situation où quand cet
homme l'aimait il faisait souvent un peu
ce qu'elle voulait donc elle avait la
main pour dire un mot plus plus neutre
que dominant et évidemment là
elle a
tellement donc cré d'instabilité dans ce
couple que cet homme a commencé
à ne plus l'aimer et puis il est tombé
amoureux d'un autre et donc évidemment
elle perd la main et elle le supporte
pas nathalie leskrill est une femme
impulsive et violente certains témoins
vont d'ailleurs en faire les frais je me
rappelle quand je parlais j'ai croisé le
le regard de Nathalie et j'ai rarement
croisé un un un regard comme ça d'une
détermination d'une
j'aurais je pensais au regard d'un aigle
elle était déterminée elle était c'est
c'est même incroyable il y avait aucune
tendresse aucune aucune compassion
aucune
apparemment aucun remord dans son dans
dans son regard enfin le coup de grâce
contre toute attente est portée par la
propre sœur de l'accusé ça sœuré se
montre
particulièrement virulente avec Nathalie
en disant que c'est c'est une qu'elle la
croit capable de tout que sa sœur est
vraiment la présente comme un monstre
elle en brosse un portrait mais alors
absolument démoniaque et et ça personne
s'y attendait c'est vraiment elle a
surpris tout le monde en se comportant
comme ça face à ces témoignages
accablant la défense de lerill tente de
minimiser les fait pour elle il ne
s'agit pas d'un meurtre prémédité
l'accusé agit sous l'emprise de la
colère et a perdu son sang
froid reste à savoir si cela suffira à
obtenir la clémence des
juré le 23 novembre
1996 après quatre longues heures de
délibérer le verdict tombe il est 3h du
matin 20 ans de tirs de sûreté c'est
lourd c'est long Nathalie quand elle
entend cette peine de 20 ans qui qui
tombe est évidemment effondré et c'est
normal et le père s'est levé a insulté
l'avocat général en lui disant vous êtes
content vous avez eu ce que vous vouliez
vous allez bien dormir cette
nuit Nathalie lesrill a immédiatement
été incarcérée à la prison de ais grâce
au jeu des remises de peine et parce
qu'elle a su prouver qu'elle pouvait se
réinsérer la jeune femme est aujourd'hui
libre après avoir passé 8 années
derrière les
barreaux